on va jouer aux cow en boîte au bois
bois tabac c'est parti il avait réclamé
vous allez donner des conseils
voilà qui est avec nous pour jouer on se
détend landes et bien on est ce soir
shebab alors on est tranquille
comment ça va ma chérie quand on
s'appelle entière quand comment toute
attitude angel c'est la ouate chez patou
wah wah gadea des oies
à bella à angela tu fais quoi dans la
vie je suis la maman au foyer j'adore
maman oui au foyer était comme un soleil
t art est à combien d'enfants ma chérie
j'en ai dû avec moi la deux avec toi
comme ils s'appellent g charlotte qui a
5 ans et j'ai rose qui à 14 euros
charlotte et rosa couchot photo
charlotte et l'amendé le premier veut
gars dans l'équipe il ya maintenant une
fille qui a du punch
merci et la tabbee tout ma chérie j
entends des mois en vendée
j'adore ma série j'ai peut-être 5000
euros pour toi ce soir
mille euros c'est le jeu des boîtes dans
un instant tu fera la connaissance de
notre banquier merzoug blanchard un bien
selon la banque nationale de ouarzazate
la bmo et ma chérie tu vas pouvoir
remporter beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
sous et c'est important pour toi c'est
important pour nous c'est parti quelle
boîte choisis tu déjà quelle boîte mais
tu de côté entre la haine et la vie tu
habites boîte et ben je prendre l'a7 de
koné l'a7 l'a7
alors je t'explique ma chérie je vais
aller chercher les boîtes tu vas pouvoir
gagner donc jusqu'à 5000 euros ce soir
il y a dans les boîtes une paire de
babouches taille 38 un pèse personne
un mini golf pour toilettes un
smartphone 100 euros 500 euros 1000
euros 5000 euros un axe fort tu dois ici
je le pose ici comme ça vous savez ce
qu'il est et bien sûr je vous rappelle
que le magasin va bientôt faire des
grosses sommes
alors c'est parti tu prends la boîte
numéro 7 jamais les boiboite les bois
boîtes sont là on va jouer tous ensemble
vous ne la verrez donc la boîte numéro 7
elle est là c'est bon c'est parti c'est
fini quelle boîte élimine tueur premier
la cat la cape l'a4
tu prends la cape et méfiez vous voyez
là j'en voyais l'a7 valdinguer la fiche
alors la 4c la première boîte que tuer
des mines ma chérie là c'est la 4 oui
angela tu vient d'éliminer
une somme ont bien tu vient d'éliminer
sans l'eau ça va ça va bon c'est quand
même un beau cadeau 100 euros mais pour
l'instant tu t'en sors 100 euros c'est
mort il tresse tous les autres cadeaux
essaie d'éliminer les cadeaux les plus
pourris pour rappel ici bien entendu il
ya une paire de babouches un ovale
symbole sur toile est alors tu prends
quelle boîte quelle boîte et divine tu
maintenant je vais éliminer la cinq
places 5
l'a5 la 5
attention la 5 les chroniqueurs est-ce
que vous la sentez la 5 - maria renda la
saq
laurence fatton sous lens parce que
laurence tu vient d'éliminer la boîte à
milon a émergé blanchard est avec nous
notre banquier qui veut déjà te faire
une première proposition
il te reste la boîte à 5000 la boîte à
500 le smartphone le mini golf pour
toilettes le pèse personne et la paire
de babouches taille 38 bonsoir merci à
bercy ou de lancer ares merci aux la bmo
de la banque nationale de ouarzazate
merci merci merci merci merci merci
d'être là les rejoue qu est ce qu est ce
que tu as une première proposition à
faire à angela alors autre gène a
enchanté oui oui je vous je vous achète
votre boîte tenez vous bien à 15 euros
15 euros pour voir nom d'à côté
merci de me traite pas aussi des autres
elle va continuer apparemment est le
banquier était en faillite il ya plus de
dix ans robert à disposition au sud
première font pas tout et milan c'est ch
et tu as bien raison mon merzoug
blanchard et ne parle pas comme ça tu
risquerais d'exciter laurent seigne
angela ma chérie quelle boîte et
diminuer la une la une allez la une
angela j'espère que tu vas gagner une
belle somme je rappelle que tu es maman
au foyer
labine tulle élimine tu as mis l'a72
côté angela la une la une ça mille euros
tu viens de faire de la boîte à 5000
orange et la crise est là à temps c'est
pas grave ma chérie il te reste quand
même la boîte à 500 euros encore il faut
tout pour tu passes tout ce qu'ils ont
tout pouvoir pour gagner la boîte à 500
euros ce serait une magnifique somme
sans sourire ou comme ça sur un coup de
fil il te reste quatre boîtes à laquelle
élimine tous malades de la grippe est là
il faut éliminer toutes les mauvaises
boîte à malice tu élimines le smartphone
les smartphones tu as encore la boîte à
300 euros
attention il te reste un mini golf pour
perse port aux toilettes un pèse
personne et une paire de babouches
taille 38 laquelle et 10 minutes
il me reste à 6 sur l'a6 là si on enlève
la six j'espère que dans la sicile n'ya
pas les 500 boul
les 500 boul angela tu élimines le pèse
personne pour une paire ses mots pour
l'instant il te reste de trois boîtes
mais la tienne la numéro secte tue
encore la possibilité de gagner 500
euros angela aubois boîte de baba
merzoug nos chars d'intervenir à tout
moment pour te refaire une nouvelle
proposition à bastia justement merzoug
blanchard et la mairie tu as cheminot
est tout à l'heure 15 euros
reste la boîte à 500 euros il reste la
paire de babouches et le minigolf pour
toilettes
combien proposes-tu rangers
angela oui je vous propose de vous
racheter votre boîte à 250 euros et un
pad ebe autour de 150 euros et un panini
au thon c'est pas mal c'est une belle
proposition il te reste que trois boigny
angela il te reste trois boîtes et eut
encore la boîte à 500 euros
qu'est ce que tu fais angela est ce que
tu te tente encore une boîte
cyril way laquelle lmcu dockers est la 3
l'a8 et la tienne la secte l'adjoint
entre la royal navy
tu élimines lavit
[Musique]
angela tu vient d'éliminer la paire de
babouches taille chronos et s c'est pas
mal il nous reste donc la boîte à 500
euros et le minigolf pour toilettes mais
la boîte c'est la boîte numéro secte
ouais et il te reste là trois éliminés
le banquier merzoug blanchard est ce que
vous avez une proposition à faire à jeun
angela déjà je vous propose de renvoyer
la paire de babouches s'il vous plaît
elle pas elle part tout de suite ne vous
inquiétez pas pour commencer j'ai reçu
oui alors alors attention je fais péter
les compteurs savéan batna dans la vie
vaut mieux prendre ce qui a je vous
achète votre boîte à 300 euros
trois mille dirhams 300 euros et à
angela angela vous avez une chance sur
deux une chance sur deux pour angela est
ce que dans votre boîte numéro 7 il ya
les 500 euros ou bien est-ce que les 500
heureux sont dans la boîte numéro 3 ou
est ce que vous allez me dire non je
vais prendre les 300 euros de bouder
parce que je préfère jouer la sécurité
angela c'est vous qui a décidé je prends
mes marques
quand même alors il permettre oui alors
vas-y vas-y je me permettant de gérer
vous allez soit gagner 300 euros ça
c'est ce qui est sûr et certain
voilà 100 euros je m'y engage
personnellement à les enlever de la paix
de castaldi ou alors aux jo quitte ou
double à roulette russe rasoir angela
vous prenez les 300 euros de l'air sur
ou pas la sécurité web et des blancs
chez moi ça aurait bien
angela honda doit vous envoler la boîte
numéro 3 oui bah oui oui
vous auriez garder la boîte numéro 7
donc entier la voilà c'est ça et bien
dans la boîte numéro 7
angela il y avait ce sera sans moi c'est
pas grave il ya la parade avec claude
gênât angela qui gagne 300 euros avec
nous et les boîtes de balles grâce aux
phoques est vraiment belle aventure en
haut d'un combi jaune je la remercie
d'avancé avec mes chéris merci on t'aime
fort merci d'avoir été là